The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NANCY KANWISHER: Auditory
cortex is fun to study,
because very few people do it.
So you study vision, you have
to read hundreds of papers
before you get off the ground.
You study audition, you
can read three papers,
then you get to play.
It's great.
So there's consensus
about tonotopy,
I mentioned this before.
This is an inflated brain,
oriented like this top
of the temporal lobe.
High, low, high frequencies.
OK.
That's like retinotopy, but
for primary auditory cortex.
So this has been known forever.
Many people have reported
it in animals and humans.
Oops, we'll skip the high
and low sounds, right.
So there are lots of claims
about the organization
of the rest of auditory
cortex outside that.
But basically,
there's no consensus.
You know, nobody knows
how it's organized.
So what we set out to do, was to
take a very different approach
from everything I've
talked about so far.
We said, let's kind of try
to figure out how high level
auditory cortex is organized.
Not by coming up with one
fancy little hypothesis,
and a beautifully designed
pair of contrast conditions
to test each little hypothesis.
What we usually do.
Let's just scan people
listening to lots of stuff,
and use some data driven method
to kind of shake the data.
And see what falls out.
OK.
To be really technical about it.
So when I say we, this is
really Sam Norman-Haignere
did all of this.
And as this project got
more and more mathematically
sophisticated, I
got more and more
taken over by Josh McDermott,
who knows about audition.
And knows a lot of fancy
math, much more than I do.
They're fabulous collaborators.
OK.
So basically, what do we do?
The first thing you want to
do, especially when you're
using these data driven
methods to broadly characterize
a region of the brain,
is a major source of bias
in the structure you discover,
is the stimuli you use.
So with vision, you
have a real problem.
You can't just scan people
looking at everything,
because there's too much.
Right?
You know, can't keep people
in the scanner for 20 hours.
And so, you have a problem
of how to choose it.
And as your selection of
stimuli shape what you find,
and it's kind of a mess.
With audition, it
turns out that there's
a relatively small number
of basic level sounds
that people can recognize.
So if you guys all write down--
you don't have to do this,
but just to illustrate.
If you all write
down three frequently
heard sounds that are
easily recognizable,
that you encounter
regularly in your life.
The three sounds that you wrote
down are on our list of 165.
Because, in fact, there are
not that many different sounds.
And so we did this on the web.
We played people sounds.
And obviously depends
on the grain, right.
If it's this person's voice,
versus that person's voice,
there are hundreds of thousands.
Right.
But at the grain
of person speaking,
dog barking, toilet
flushing, ambulance siren.
At that grain,
there's only a couple
hundred sounds that everyone
can pretty much recognize
in a two second clip, and
that they hear frequently.
And that's really
lovely, because it
means we can scan subjects
listening to all of them.
And we don't have
this selection bias.
So we basically
tile the space of
recognizable, frequently-heard,
natural sounds.
And we scan subjects
listening to all of it.
OK so here are
some of our sounds.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
It's supposed to
either rain or snow.
[END PLAYBACK]
This is our list of frequency.
Most common, man speaking.
Second most common,
toilet flushing.
And so forth.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Hannah is good at compromising.
[VAROOM]
[END PLAYBACK]
So we pop subjects
in the scanner,
and we scan them while they
listen to these sounds.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CLACK, CLACK, CLACK]
[VAROOM]
[END PLAYBACK]
Anyway, you get the idea.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[WATER RUSHING]
[GASP]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
So we scan them while they
listen to these sounds.
And then what we get is
a 165 dimensional vector
describing the response
profile for each voxel.
OK.
So each voxel in
the brain, we say
how strong was the response
to each of those sounds?
And we get something like this.
Everybody with me?
Sort of?
OK.
So now what we do
is, we take all
of those voxels that are in
greater suburban auditory
cortex, which is just like
a whole big region around,
including but far beyond
primary auditory cortex.
Anything in that zone
that responds to any
of these sounds, is in the net.
And we take all of those, and
we put them into a huge matrix.
OK.
So this is now all of the
voxels from auditory cortex,
in 10 different subjects.
OK, 11,000 voxels.
And so we've got 11,000
voxels by 165 sounds.
OK.
So now the cool
thing is, what we
do is, we throw away the
labels on the matrix.
And just apply math.
And say, what is the
dominant structure in here?
OK.
And what I love about that
is, this is a way to say,
in a very,
theory-neutral way, what
are the basic dimensions
of representation
that we have in auditory cortex?
Not, can I find evidence
for my hypothesis.
But, let's look broadly
and let the data
tell us what the major
structure is in there.
OK.
So basically what we do
is, factorise this matrix.
And probably half of you would
understand this better than me.
But just to describe
it, basically, we
do a-- it's not exactly
independent component analysis,
but it's a version of that.
Actually, multiple
versions of this that
have slightly
different constraints.
Because of course,
there are many ways
to factorise this matrix.
It's an unconstrained
problem, so you
need to bring some constraints.
We'd try to bring in minimalist
ones in several different ways.
It turns out, the results really
don't depend strongly on this.
And so, the cool thing is that
the structure that emerges
is not based on any hypothesis
about functional profiles.
Because the labels are not
even used in the analysis.
And it's not based on any
assumption about the anatomy
of auditory cortex.
Because the locations
of these voxels
are not known by the analysis.
OK.
OK so basically, the
assumption of this analysis
goes like this.
Each voxel, as I
lamented earlier,
is hundreds of
thousands of neurons.
So the hope here is that there's
a relatively small number
of kinds of neural populations.
And that, each one has a
distinctive response profile
over those 165 sounds.
And that voxels have
different ratios
of the different neural
population types.
OK.
And so, further, we
assume that there's
this smallish number of sort
of canonical response profiles.
Such that we can model
the response of each voxel
as a linear weighted sum of
some small number of components.
OK.
And so, the goal
then is to discover
what those components are.
And the idea is that each
component is basically
the response profile and
the anatomical distribution
of some neural population.
OK.
So let me just do that
one other way here.
So we're going to
take this matrix,
and we're going to factorise
it into some set of end
components.
And each of those
components is going
to have 165 dimensional vector
of its response profile.
OK.
Each component will also
have a weight matrix
across the relevant
voxels there.
OK.
Telling us how
much that component
contributes to each voxel.
OK.
And then we use, sort of,
ICA to find these components.
OK.
The first thing
you do, of course,
in any of these problems
is, OK, how many?
And so, actually Sam did
a beautiful analysis,
the details of which I'll skip.
Because they're complicated,
because I actually
don't remember all of them.
But essentially, you can
split the data in half.
Model one whole half, and
measure how much variance is
accounted for in left-out data.
And what you find is that,
variance accounted for goes up
'til six components.
And then goes down, because
you start over fitting, right.
So we know that there are
six components in there.
Now, that doesn't
mean there are only
six kinds of neural populations.
That's, in part, a
statement about what we can
resolve with functional MRI.
But we know that
with this method,
we're looking for
six components.
That's what it finds.
And so, to remind
you, the cool thing
about the components that
we're going to get out,
which I'll tell you
about in a second,
is that nothing
about this analysis
constrain those components.
There are no assumptions
that went in there, right.
So if you think about
it, if all we can resolve
for the response of each
voxel to each sound is,
say, high versus low.
That's conservative.
I think we can
resolve, you know,
a finer grain of
magnitude of response.
But even if it's
just high or low,
there are 2 to the 165 possible
response profiles in here.
Right.
We're searching a massive space.
Anything is possible.
Right.
And similarly, the anatomical
weight distributions
are completely
unconstrained, with respect
to whether they're
clustered, overlapping,
a speckly mess, any
of those things.
OK.
So what did we find?
I just said all this.
OK, so we're looking for
the response profiles
and their distribution.
OK speckly mess, right.
Just said that.
OK.
So what we get with the response
profiles is, four of them
are things we already knew
about auditory cortex.
One is high frequency
selectivity,
and one is low
frequency selectivity.
That's tonotopic cortex.
That's the one thing
we knew really solidly.
A third thing we
find is a response
to pitch, which is
different than frequency.
I'll skip the details.
But we'd actually
published a paper the year
before, showing that there's
a patch of cortex that
likes pitch in particular.
And that, that's not
the same as frequency.
And it popped out as
one of the components.
A fourth one is a somewhat
controversial claim
about spectral temporal
modulation, which many people
have written about.
The idea that this is
somehow a useful basis
set in auditory representations.
And we found what seems to
be a response that fits that.
OK.
So all of those are
either totally expected,
or kind of in line with
a number of prior papers.
It's the last two that
are the cool ones.
OK.
And the numbers-- actually,
the numbers refer to--
never mind.
The numbers are
largely arbitrary.
The numbers are for
dramatic effect, really.
Component four.
OK.
So here's what one of these
last two components is.
So now what we have
is, this is a magnitude
of response of that component.
Remember, component
is two things.
It's got this profile
here, and it's
got the distribution
over the cortex.
So this is the profile
to the 165 sounds.
The colors refer to different
categories of sound.
We put them on
Mechanical Turk and had
people stick 1 of 10
different familiar labels.
And so dark green is
English speech and light
green is foreign speech, not
understood to the subjects.
This just pops right out.
We didn't twiddle.
We didn't fuss.
We didn't look for this,
it just popped out.
And light blue is singing.
So this is a response to speech,
a really selective response
to speech.
It's not language,
because it doesn't care
if it's English or foreign.
So this is not something about
representing language meaning,
it's about representing
the sounds of speech that
are present here, and to
some extent in vocal music.
Pretty amazing.
Now there have been a number
of reports from functional MRI
and from intracranial
recordings,
suggesting cortical regions
selected for speech.
This wasn't completely
unprecedented,
although it's
certainly the strongest
evidence for specificity.
You can see that in
this profile here.
Right.
Dark purple is the
next thing you get to
after the language
and the singing.
So you get all the way down
before you're at dark purple.
And dark purple is non-speech
human vocalizations,
stuff like laughing,
and crying, and singing.
Right.
Which are similar in some ways.
Not exactly speech,
but it's similar.
So that's damn selective.
Pretty cool.
Yeah?
OK.
I just said all that.
OK the other component is
even cooler, and here it is.
OK.
Here's the code.
Non-vocal music and
vocal music, or singing.
This is a music
selective response.
This has never been
reported before.
Many people have looked.
We have looked, it
hasn't been found.
We think that we were
able to find this music
selective response.
In fact, we have
evidence that we
were able to find this
music selective response.
In large part, because of the
use of this linear weighting
model.
If you then--
I got to show you where these
things are in the brain.
OK.
Running out of time, so
I'm accelerating here.
We did a bunch of
low level acoustic
controls to show that these
things really are selective.
You can't account for them.
They don't get the same
response if you scramble them.
They really have to do with the
structure of speech and music.
I'll skip all that.
Right.
So now we can take those
things, those components,
and project them
back of the brain.
And say, where are they?
OK.
So first, let's do
the reality check.
Here's tonotopic cortex mapped
in the usual hypothesis-driven
way.
And now, we're going to put
outlines, just as landmarks,
on the high and low frequency
parts of tonotopic cortex.
And so, I mentioned before
that, one of the components
was low frequencies.
Here it is.
Perfectly aligning
with frequency mapping,
that this one pops out of
the natural sound experiment,
the ICA on the natural sounds.
And this one is based on
hypothesis-driven mapping.
So that's a nice reality check.
But what about speech cortex?
Well, here it is.
OK.
So the white and black outlines
are primary auditory cortex.
And you see this band of speech
selectivity right below it.
Situated strategically between
auditory cortex and language
cortex, which is right
below it, actually.
Not shown here, but we
know from other studies.
So that's pretty cool.
Here's where the music stuff is.
It's anterior of
primary auditory cortex.
And there's a little
bit behind it as well.
OK.
So we think we were able to
find the music selectivity,
when it wasn't found
before with functional MRI.
Because this method
enables us to discover
selective components, even
if they overlap within
voxels with other components.
Because our linear
weighting model
takes it apart and discovers
the underlying latent component,
which may be very selective.
Even if, in all of
the voxels, it's
mixed in with something else.
So actually, if you go in and
you look at the same data.
And you say, let's
look for voxels
that are individually very music
selective, you can't really
find them.
Because they overlap a little
bit with the pitch response
and with some of
the other stuff.
So the standard methods
can't find the selectivity
in the way that we
can with this kind
of mathematical decomposition,
which is really thrilling.
I can say one more thing,
and I'll take a question.
And the final thing is, we have
recently had the opportunity
to reality check this stuff,
by using intracranial recording
from patients who
have electrodes right
on the surface of their brain.
And we've done this
in three subjects now.
And in each subject, we see--
sorry, this is hard to see.
These are responses of two
different electrodes over time.
So the stimulus
last two seconds.
So that's 0 to 2 seconds.
This is time.
And this is a speech
selective electrode
responding to native speech,
foreign speech, and singing.
And here is another
electrode that
responds to instrumental music
in purple, and singing in blue.
And so what this shows is, we
can validate the selectivity.
With intracranial recording,
we can see that selectivity
in individual
electrodes, that you
can't see in individual voxels.
So that sort of
validates having to go
through the tunnel of math
to infer the latent selective
components underneath.
Because we can see
them in the raw data
in the intracranial recording.
So this is cool,
because nobody even
knows why people have
music in the first place.
And so the very idea that
there are, apparently,
bits of brain that
are selectively
engaged in processing music,
is radical, and fascinating,
and deeply puzzling.
So, you know, one
of the speculations
about why we have music--
Steve Pinker famously
wrote in one of his books
that music is
auditory cheesecake.
By which he meant that, music
is not like some special purpose
thing, it just pings a bunch
of preexisting mechanisms.
Like, you know, fat, and
sweet, and all that stuff.
Right.
And so that idea is that music
kind of makes use of mechanisms
that exist for other reasons.
And I think this
argues otherwise.
If you have selective
brain regions,
we don't know that
they're innate.
They're quite possibly learned.
But they sure
aren't piggybacking
on other mechanisms.
Those regions are pretty
selective for music,
as far as we can tell.